yeah sure he's played the game a certain
style for this whole career and he's
done it at a pretty high level so I
think you know just some of the things
that he's been able to really enhance
within our offenses has been you know a
lot of fun to watch you saw like that
off schedule play that he made down in
the red zone you made another one to
Jake [ __ ] row where you know I didn't
just paint the ball going where I went
but that's where it went you know a
touchdown so that's Matt Lafleur last
week talking about Aaron Rodgers the
Packers quarterback one of the greatest
quarterbacks of all time Chris you and I
agree on that yeah you put him at the
very top but I live like I do but but
there's that tension now between being
the playmaker and being the play call or
the quote that we mentioned earlier and
you could see Mike Silver there in the
background as Matt Lafleur was talking
Rodgers to silver regarding the lack of
freedom that the Lafleur offense gives
to the quarterback at the line of
scrimmage Rodgers saying I've got 11
years and that counts for something and
there aren't many people who can spot
the things at the line of scrimmage that
I can and he's right about he is right
about you you get into your mid to late
30s your brain is a football
supercomputer your body as long as it
still will allow you to do the things
that the brain tells the body to do
you're in a sweet spot where your coach
on the field exactly why would you want
it why would you want now setting aside
the question of whether Aaron Rodgers
should be talking about that to a
reporter or anyone else who isn't part
of the Packers why wouldn't you want
Aaron Rodgers to be making changes that
the line of scrimmage press well I think
that's what I listen Mike I read this
tweet I tried to go into the show today
not looking at the context of all the
tweet as we went over in the first hour
okay so I'm hashing this out kind of on
on my on the go here either way but to
me you kind of just unveiled the problem
with the things you just said I mean
that's what it reads like to me it reads
like to me that at this point right now
and this can happen when you have a new
coaching staff new offensive head coach
new offensive coordinator they might
just say hey Aaron and practice right
now just run the play just run the play
we want to instill our install our
offense and everybody get on the
same page you know let's not do the
checks and all those kind of things
right now and maybe they went through
road TAS a mini camp or he didn't get to
do much of the line of scrimmage and
maybe he's voiced his opinion on that a
little bit and maybe he just feels like
this gives it a little bit more pressure
or urgency within the coaching staff
Mike to make sure that this does happen
in training camp that would be my two
cents just kind of reading between the
lines right now because you're exactly
right so many of the big plays that
Aaron Rodgers makes on a yearly basis
come at the line of scrimmage because
hey he's getting people who were not you
know they're substituting and they're
not getting off the field in time or he
sees something any signals real quick
and they run a play that's fifteen or
twenty yards so I would imagine those
are some of the issues that are
bothering Rodgers now like you said him
airing it out publicly you know that is
not gonna get perceived nicely by
everybody we know that and and let's
think about the broader context here
remember the article from Tyler Dunn of
bleacher report they included if I call
recall correctly and there's a chance I
don't but wasn't there some stuff in
there about Rodgers basically ignoring
what Mike McCarthy wanted to do and
doing his own thing right so you've
already got this indictment of Rodgers
and his relationship with the last coach
and Rodgers keenly aware of that
criticism he reacted to it
he and some former teammates tried to
shout it all down I you know and and one
thing I've always credited Aaron Rodgers
with being for the most part is very
self-aware yeah how do you allow
yourself to put yourself in position to
have that that same yeah from get banged
just a few months after this Tyler Dunn
story yeah I know it I mean is it one he
just doesn't care and just goes you know
what the greater good for the team and
the situation here is for me to air this
out a little bit to put the pressure on
the coaches or as to did he lose
self-awareness here with a guy Mike
silver who's a Cal graduate I mean I'm a
big fan of Mike silver he's a great guy
and he can make you feel real
comfortable in a conversation you know
real quickly so did he get too
comfortable and maybe share a little bit
much with a cow graduate and Othello
alumni that he didn't really mean to but
either way yeah we're gonna talk about
it because it is a rod
and there is a you know Inklings and
history of this type of talk with him so
I understand that others who have fallen
victim to that yeah have later said that
they didn't say what they said or it was
out of context or something like that it
will be interesting to see at what point
Rogers says I really didn't say that or
you know it's being presented in a
context that really was and you know cuz
cuz Silver's had to fight that in the
past right wrong or otherwise the
allegation that he either either didn't
get the quote that he said he got or the
quote was exaggerated or the quote was
taken out of context and it always
stands by it and I'm not saying that
this isn't accurate I'm just saying that
that could be something that Rogers
chooses to do right if this ends up
being a bigger deal then maybe it
otherwise could be
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports